[Music]
we're continuing our partnership with
learn liberty today and joining me is
the president and CEO of the Thurgood
Marshall scholarship fund the only
national organization representing the
nearly three hundred thousand students
attending America's forty seven
historically black colleges Johnny C
Taylor
welcome to the Reuben report so glad to
be here I got to tell you man I and I
just did tell you about now I'll repeat
it since the cameras are on you we've
been doing this thing with learn Liberty
for a little over a year or so and
they've sent us some great authors and
professors and thinkers I've never
requested anyone you sir
are the first person I requested because
I saw you speak a couple months back at
a conference for academics had to do a
lot about free speech and liberty and
all sorts of things and you gave the
keynote address on the final night and I
thought this guy is possibly the most
passionate speaker I've ever seen in my
life thank you
where does that passion come from well
let's start there before we even talk
about what you do just the passion that
you had I was just like that I gotta get
that guy on the show
so it's interesting I spent my career in
the entertainment space the media space
Paramount Pictures Spelling
entertainment blockbuster entertainment
so all of my life was doing that kind of
stuff making money right but I always
had this yearning for the community and
and how higher education could play into
in you know sort of fixing what was
going on in my community and I say the
community I mean all of Americans but
particularly african-americans and there
were so many conversations that didn't
occur weren't allowed to occur and so I
took this new role at the Thurgood
Marshall College Fund representing black
colleges I didn't attend a black college
I often say I'm a beneficiary of it
because so many of my teachers and
doctors and lawyers did but I didn't my
merits didn't attend to black college
but I thought this was such an
opportunity to come in and really begin
to influence how young people you know
our future leaders how they think about
the world and then to challenge them my
legal education by definition sort of
taught me to challenge the status quo to
be able to argue both sides or in some
instances three sides of any argument
and so that's what came from I really I
don't sleep at night sometimes thinking
about where America is headed and that's
where the passion comes from I'm
genuinely concerned about where we're
going yeah I feel that too and we kind
of hit that a little bit before now we
got to do it all over right now tell me
a little bit more about your resume
before we get to what you've been doing
these last couple years because yeah you
just mentioned some of us up I mean
you've got a pretty prime your
linkedin's got to be pretty fast in the
last somewhat like eight pages that's
right god is good
but tell me a little bit about that cuz
I think it does form sort of you know
how you end up sitting across from me
here yes so I began my career well let
me back up I did the undergraduate work
in the University of Miami I'm a born
and raised in Florida so I'm for you I
gotta give my shout out to my school and
even I finished school went to law
school in Iowa Drake University and I
came back to South Florida to practice
at a big law firm Janet Reno was one of
my was the first female partner so I'm
hating myself it takes your way back
yeah and then began my practice sat on a
plane one day melt met a I did not know
at the time a billionaire wayne Huizenga
who had this small little business
called blockbuster that he was building
I went in as the third lawyer on staff
and literally we went through this huge
acquisition spree and you know you
remember blockbuster was on every corner
in Seville yeah so did that Vikon bodice
so I've spent my time as a lawyer as an
HR executive and then ultimately once
vikon bought us and worked for some
there at Vikon Sumner Redstone and then
my last corporate gig was running a
business a subsidiary for Barry Diller
in New York so I literally have had all
the back office functions and then ran
front line operator running a business
for Barry yeah came to TMC up in 2010 as
the CEO so you've been doing this for
now about seven years and you're
actually about to shift onto something
else between which we'll get to a little
later yes but tell me a little bit about
what the scholarship fund actually does
what is the purpose because I know a
certain amount of people because I know
a lot of your thoughts on on the
diversity memo and all that stuff it
almost sounds counter to what the
Thurgood Marshall scholarship fund might
do right so the the college fund was
actually created by the way we were
created as the scholarship fund
Thurgood Marshall scholarship fund about
a decade ago we changed the name to
broaden the remit to the college fund
since they're good Marshall college fund
and we really only do four things
scholarships we provide scholarships for
the absolutely most talented students so
this is not sort of a social services
feel-good for kids who didn't get a shot
K through 12 these are the brightest
kids who frankly just have money not
what they need so scholarships that are
needed and sort of need and merit-based
then capacity building we've talked with
our schools a lot about there was a time
when HBCUs captive market if you were
black anyone to go to college you
attended a black college well everything
changed be careful what you pray for we
asked for diversity we got it we asked
for integration we got it and so now
black students have options and so black
colleges the historically black colleges
have got to step up so the second thing
is to build their capacity to be
attractive the third thing that we do is
government affairs I mean a lot of
advocacy and policy work to make sure
that we're not making emotional
decisions we want to do what is good for
our communities and what's good for this
country those are really the three
things that we focus on as as a fund and
that's the work that we do and the thing
that that most of the folks frankly
don't realize is historically black
colleges are not EBC used they're not
exclusively black colleges in fact for
currently four of our member schools
aren't majority white really majority
white so they are still historically
black colleges because the H is
historically black not necessarily
currently black yeah so West Virginia
State in Bluefield State College both in
West Virginia Lincoln University in
Missouri Kentucky State these are
schools that while technically are not
technically are actually HBCUs are have
more white students than black students
and those are some of the things that
people don't understand this is not
about race per se yeah how much battling
is there over what it means to be
historically black versus currently
diverse because I would imagine you've
got you know ideas and and
hammocks and administrators who are
probably pretty entrenched in keeping
things just looking at it by numbers not
necessarily diversity of thought that's
and all that so you must be dealing with
that constant oh you have no idea ugly
and it's interesting because I'm
surprised and I know we'll talk about
some of this but I'm surprised at the
number you'd like to think millenials
you know we think Millennials and we
group the men in their open and they're
diverse in their well I was surprised
we've had some students really not
faculty not alumni but students 18 your
19 year olds take great issue with the
fact that the institutions are more
diverse than they were they wanted to
come to an all-black institution anyway
get there and realize that we have
international students and white
students and Hispanic students they
really push back so that's been a real
surprise to me yeah how do you break
through that well you you continue first
of all you explain to them that HBCU is
not EB C you then you start with it and
then you also then explain I find myself
to oftentimes when I'm talking to them
saying let me just put yourself in this
situation so just recently one of our
campuses really what does a group of
students really upset because in fact it
was all of the national news well
students came on the campus of Howard
University wearing the make America
great again oh yeah that's right and I
said I just one of the student leaders
that pull to the status I don't want you
just for a second to ask me how do you
think this will play out good for black
students right after Obama selected go
visit Liberty University's campus they
have on the wonderful Obama t-shirts
where they're proud of this new
president and they were literally run
off of campus they were threatened they
were harassed how do you think that will
go over and so what I find myself doing
is just literally put yourself in that
situation and tell me why this is that
different and then you get that pause
that moment by the way that's what
motivates me to do my work because
that's the way you influence the sort of
the narrative
yeah and how these young people think
you have to just stop and say I get how
you feel right now emotionally about
this but for just a second let's flip
the script and tell me how this works
and you're smart you're bright yeah tell
me how this works out that's that's
really part of what motivates me to do
the work yeah and that's what we need
more all right I mean because everybody
seems
hysterics hysterical over over emotional
steps like it's see like I can
understand that if I if I was black and
I wanted to go to a historically black
college and I got there and I thought it
was going to be 80% black and I got
there and I was like wait a minute I'm
actually still a minority here the the
emotional part I can understand it being
like this doesn't feel right to me but
then when you hear that and you go well
things actually are changing integration
is really this is this is all good this
is this is the purpose right freedom
prayed for right you know I often say be
careful what you pray for this is
exactly what we said we wanted is the
opportunity to choose kind of that's
what I can tell you that's what my
great-grandparents yeah that's what I
got in fact Thurgood Marshall himself
what folks don't realize this Thurgood
Marshall didn't choose to go to Howard
University Law School Thurgood Marshall
fact of the matter is applied to the
University of Maryland was denied
admission to that law school when I went
to Howard because it was the college for
black students law students for black
students and so you just have to think
about it he then subsequently brought
lawsuits to actually stop that very
thing again this was an anti HBCU the
message was I want to be able to choose
irrespective of my skin color where I go
to school so all of us should have
predicted that we would be right where
we are today yeah what I find is the
young folks just don't understand the
history and then the older people refuse
to tell the honest history so what's
going on there because I don't play
there is so much nonsense the media is
so complicit in this yes I I don't you
know and identity Pollock says has
become so rooted in everything that I
don't blame the young people who are
misguided yeah I want to get through to
that and all that it's the other people
that you're talking with the older
people and the academics that are afraid
to speak what happened there did you see
it change
I did I saw it you know and and where I
when I was in school you were encouraged
to be a little bit of a provocateur
always respectfully you never there was
no no one wanted you to go out and hurt
someone's feelings but we were
encouraged in law school for example to
look at things from all different sorts
of perspectives I was given a case once
where you'd have to represent the
plaintiff and then turn around and go
against that winner you know defend them
so we've just lost that in education now
and I got to tell you more and more I'm
talking to students who say you know I
feel a certain way but I know that if I
either utter those my thoughts even in a
question format in the classroom I'd be
attacked but from my professor it would
impact my participation in class Green
or that that portion of my grade also
and more importantly what do you say to
kids I say when they say that perhaps
you're at the wrong school I said you
got a boat with your feet College is not
about it's supposed to be a time to
explore and to grow if you already knew
what you needed to know to sort of live
in life and be successful then you don't
need to spend five or six years and
hundreds of thousands of dollars if you
aren't the same person that you walked
in the door at the end of your freshman
year then you were cheated yeah and I
tell them you should challenge the
institution and give you a better
education and sometimes that the way you
get better is to have to confront ideas
that you don't necessarily embrace you
don't understand them one situation that
that sort of comes up and I think it
helps my students a lot understand where
I come from I said you know listen I was
an employment lawyer early in my career
and at that time there was a big
question for example around whether or
not gay lesbian sexual orientation was
covered under Title 7 mm-hmm okay big
question gender and sex was clear if you
were being discriminated against on the
basis of something else than sort of
sexual orientation that wasn't covered I
actually brought those cases and made
those arguments I defended them that was
not the intent of the Congress and this
was ridiculous etc that gender is
something that's innate you're born that
way and well gay and lesbian maybe not
so much fast forward yeah what are you
early that's 1992 okay I think it's
important that's right to context that's
right put it in context now fast-forward
you began to evolve and grow you start
sitting down and getting to know people
who are different than you are or that
your family is or that you you just you
began to evolve and it challenges your
own notions of what is right and what is
wrong and maybe you conclude there is no
right or wrong here this is just life
that we're evolving as a human species
kind
even I've had to do that and there's so
many instances of that in my own life
and so when you begin to have
conversations in the context of the
classroom with students you see the
growth that's the beauty that should be
the beauty of it instead what I'm seeing
more and more davidís they're actually
retarding the grad students you're not
encouraged to think you come in thinking
a certain way your professors want you
to think a certain way your institution
wants you to think a certain way but
here's the problem the real problem is
then you go to work and you have to
confront the reality of you know you're
not protected in this bubble you've got
to live and work next to people who
don't look like you and frankly that's
the chalice is something that people
talk about a lot when they talk about
black colleges the only I don't question
the relevancy of HBCUs I think that's a
dumb argument it's a dumb question there
is a fair question
that is posed if you have gone to a
black elementary school middle school
grew up in a black community and then
you went to a black college the first
meaningful interaction that you can add
with people who are not black isn't a
workplace you're gonna be at a
disadvantage
yeah just practically speaking and so
you it has some downside tons of upside
by the way being a majority and minority
community black colleges give you a very
special and nurturing environment to
grow in but there's a cost to that yeah
is that just the natural evolution of
the way humans are that if you have a
legit grievance you may need a different
place or for Thurgood Marshall who did
not get accepted to the Maryland law
school so he needed a place to go to
completely legit in that time and place
but that eventually we if equality works
because the arc does bend towards
justice that eventually you slowly need
these things less it doesn't mean that
there's no use for them but you but a
lot of people are sort of addicted to
that original pain or instance or
whatever you want to call it like you
nailed it I mean that none of us it's
it's it's addictive I mean that's a
problem in weaning yourself off of that
is difficult and that's not limited to
black people or any group of people it's
just that you get used to it yeah and
this notion that we were to create
remember you
the concept of affirmative action was
supposed to be remedial mm-hmm it was
not supposed to go on forever right but
what happens is if you get used to it
and it's a benefit that a new verse to
you and people who look like you it's
really tough to one day say okay that's
done I have a seven-year-old daughter
and I you know there's a point at which
she's gonna come off of daddy's credit
card and she's gonna fight me
yeah if it's a teen if it's twenty eight
if it's 38 the day that I decide you now
have to leave the nest and figure this
out yourself if it's 38 came I move in
with you done right but you write your
lunch is something that that's um it's
even think about just in real life
that's the thing that I'm intrigued by
is I could not wait until I turned 18 so
that I could leave my nest to my mama
and my daddy's house and go and start
creating my own and I'm seeing some of
them for economic reasons but just
everyone sort of staying at home and
they want it's a very different world
that we live in right now and I'm
intrigued by it yeah how much of this
also is about the family in general
that's one of the things when I've had a
couple particularly in this case when
I've had black conservatives on you know
like larry elder talking about the black
family you just mentioned your mom and
your dad so i suspect they're still
married no they're not no okay so that
that's interesting but they were for
obviously most of us back childhood how
much of that structure is related to all
of this why then you can't necessarily
deal with outside influences or any of
that stuff so I struggle with that I
struggle with that because because of
the realities of slavery the black
community was always largely maternally
run mm-hmm dad and mom were separated
family the family unit in the
traditional sense didn't exist so and we
were successful in spite of that yeah so
I I'm not so sure that I thought now
would I
all day I think the value of having mom
and dad in the home and frankly at some
point grandparents and home to build
that in that I think it's incredibly
important but I'm not prepared to say
that's why everything is wrong as I
pointed out my parents ultimately got
we're divorced and all two have two
sisters we both went to college all
three of us rather we're successful have
great lives nobody's been to jail no one
has eight kids that you know
so I don't know that I'm prepared to say
that it's totally about sort of the
family unit I think family the one thing
that I'm happy to see now is family is
being more broadly defined mm-hmm we and
our community oftentimes talk about it
takes a village and the family could be
the little old lady cross the street if
you don't know your grandmother she
might essentially become your grandma
mm-hmm in loco parentis the concept in
Latin that that there are a whole bunch
of folks who act as parents to make it
all happen so I think we have to be a
little too careful and I hear the strict
conservatives well it's all of this is
because the family model has degraded us
a little historically I'm not so sure we
as a people in particular ever had that
yeah that's not real yeah I was
mentioning to you before also that I
just went to George Washington's estate
and yes you can go to the slave quarters
and they do a daily memorial now that
and they talk about the men living here
at the time men living here they
sometimes only got it interacts for four
minutes in a day and all sorts of stuff
yeah so you know sometimes when we have
to help people revisit history you know
this is sometimes they're like oh it was
great back in the day yeah not exactly
speaking of history I wasn't planning on
going here but as long as we're talking
about this what do you make of all the
monuments stuff happening right now
because I just read one this week that
at Christchurch and I think it's an
Alexandria they are taking down jord the
manya you know there's I think it's just
a plaque really right and I guess there
was also a plaque to Robert II leave
that upset some people so they said all
right we're gonna take down George
Washington's as well George Washington
there's no doubt he did own slaves he
freed as many as he legally could when
he died not all of them more because
some of them were technically I think
owned by Martha or her family or
something like that but as I said they
do a great memorial to them these people
were all complex people who were writing
laws to free people while they owned
people I mean it's a whole freakin thing
but me personally you want my answer
first please I'm glad to but tell me
what do you think I don't think you can
take these things down I think you can
put a counter monument next to them or a
plaque that explains more maybe you
could convince me that they can all be
moved to a museum where then you were
gonna learn about the history but I'm
very leery that there's just no ending
here that we're going to take down the
robert e lee stuff
we're gonna take down you know other
Confederate stuff but it will creep to
George Washington it will creep to
Thomas Jefferson I was just at the
memorial the words that that man wrote
about what freedom is that's the stuff
we should all care about and I just
feared that there's no ending here I
don't know if that's enough of a
justification not to take anything down
but that's really where my position is
coming from that there it won't end well
not surprisingly I violently agree with
you I I would have accepted either no I
would have given it but frankly you know
there are a couple of aha moments for me
first of all we don't like to
acknowledge this but black people home
slaves in America - that's real I mean
if the litmus test is if you own slaves
somehow we should erase from history or
put you into a museum in a little box so
that only people who visit museums will
learn about right that's why I don't
really like that actor I throw it up
there because I know that I did at
Claremont McKenna
they kid asked me and I said that he
said well what if we put him in mind as
I said all right we can play with that
one a little bit but to your point if
you take this to its I think illogical
end mm-hmm we didn't go through and
parse every person's history and we find
the one thing they did that we didn't
like which by the way at that time at
that point in the world may have been
totally the norm
yeah I'm not arguing it was good or bad
I'm just saying it was the way people
lived and it was that what was the more
a the folk way whatever of the time I
struggle with this I think you put
everything into context when I ride
through and I see a Confederate statue I
was laughing I was in a cult Alexandria
the other day yeah I have passed this
particular this switch what is it I was
just this robert e lee's the one that's
sitting right in it's just past i don't
know the street of past king street i
think it is there's a statue of this guy
on horse have passed it a number of
times and thought that's interesting
i've also I live in Washington DC on
Capitol Hill and there are all sorts of
these statues that frankly Charles
Barkley who I don't quote very him I do
a Berkeley impression I was a bargaining
president
wife with Adele thing which was really
provocative he said frankly most
african-american people aren't thinking
about that damn monument I mean it's
just we have real issues facing our
community and the idea that we have now
gotten preoccupied with these monuments
is bizarre to me and frankly and more
disturbing to me is that it's divisive
yeah any time you start peeling apart
people's history all of this is sort of
the history of the country the good and
the bad and I think that's the beauty of
telling a story and when I talk to
students about it because I've had this
conversation with some of our students
and I said do you think you know all of
us we go back into our history you're
gonna find out that your grandparents
weren't perfect people you know the
grandfather who beat on your grandmother
who cheated on your grandmother the
grandmother who well let's say back in
the day decided not to have a kid just
had a kid out of wedlock and decide to
give him to an aunt and never
acknowledged and then it was there's so
many we've all got these great bodies
guys right and the notion that somehow
you've literally made this person's life
less important because of a decision
that happened I mean all of us are
growing on this journey called life and
I just think we've gotten too serious
about it and it's also frankly divided
the country a country that is way too
divided right now I mean I've never seen
I think a Martin Luther King Lincoln
Thurgood Marshall they have to be like
sitting back somewhere looking at this
hand oh my god I can't believe once we
pulled the rules down change the laws
became a more open and free society none
of us could have thunk that this is
where we'd end up yeah and you know the
easy answer is to blame it on Trump but
the fact of the matter is this started
way before this has nothing I know so
now everyone everything right now but
I'm pretty sure some even though even
then if a protests were going on under
Obama Horse and when you talk about the
historical stuff Obama his first
president first four years was against
gay marriage right so it shouldn't be
Lou now twenty years ago it we've got to
take Obama statue or take his library
down or oh don't even start me on that
I'm so sorry on that
many countless examples you know I I was
talking to folks that there was a big
discussion about public schools and you
know we need to send all of our kids to
public schools in size timeout timeout
timeout
the Obama girls we're gonna go to school
Sidwell I know it's not very very good
for them yeah
but then you can't turn around and say
Oh public schools are wonderful they're
great for everyone when but no the
reality is they're good enough for your
children mm-hmm those are some of the
moments when we have to stop and just
pause and say you know this is it's
gotten crazy that's the point I mean I'm
so straight it with it right now
because we're picking apart people's
lives and the reality is none of us
would want someone to do the same thing
on an individual level with me you want
to pick my life apart you can come out
and say I'm a horrible person
yeah ignore the fact that I have a
beautiful seven-year-old daughter that
my parents are wonderful that I'm a good
son a good but she want to focus on the
one or two decisions that perhaps I
would have met I'm frankly I would have
done them differently if I were 48 yeah
I'm not
I was 18 yeah right yeah so yeah it's
it's we're just in an interesting spot I
know that's what you're talking about
but it disturbs me it disturbs me in
some very significant ways that I'm
raising a child in this world in this
country in particular that's not the
country I imagined it would be
yeah do you think there's any chance
that it actually is the country but it's
just the level of noise has gotten so
out of control so when we think about
you know I talk a lot about social media
and how Twitter is affecting everybody
and it's the way we all cater news to
ourselves and all that stuff but then I
took all of August offline I shut down I
was working on my book I disappeared for
a while and when I spent more time just
I mean I talked to people for a living
but outside of this room just talking to
random people I think most people do by
everything that you just said there and
I don't think that people are
necessarily as hysterical as maybe we
feel they are do you think that's
possible or is that I'm just trying to
give a real silver lining for this and I
think you're trying to feel better
because as much as we can we can't just
put the media over in a little box
particularly it used to be traditional
media but now it's social media and so
when you add all of that it really does
influence the narrative it influences
what people think
means to live in America and and I do
think we're in a very different place
now and you're right every person in the
world doesn't know what's going on a
mana for it gets charged today the
vanity of Americans don't know it work
here it's people who watch the news and
who read and who think about this who
and you know where it matters the vast
majority of Americans are like I'm
trying to keep the lights on I want to
put my kid in school and I want a decent
life and retire with some decent savings
in the bank that's more practical so I
think you're right but the influencers
people like me and you maybe not like
the two of us where is the the more
liberal media has just put it out there
so far progressively yeah they're really
crafting the narrative and the message
and it's it's it's something that we
have to pause yeah do you find yourself
with the political home because
obviously I'm in a lockstep with so much
of the things that you're so many other
things that you're talking about when I
heard you give that speech I was like
yeah yeah yeah well I mean 20 times I
was like yeah yeah yeah okay yeah yeah
do you do you I mean do you consider
yourself are you in a party or totally
independent so or as when I was in North
Carolina it was called unaffiliated that
was the phrase you weren't an
independent because there were
independents that was the N a third
party so it's unaffiliated us as kept
was a big part of Hillary Clinton's 2008
campaign raised ton of money had her in
my home financers had Erskine Bowles in
his wife I mean I was like really really
into that world I did not see that in
the research yeah yes so literally host
her in my home in North Carolina and did
a lot and then fast forward I've become
this last election frankly less enamored
so I was not involved in that campaign I
also wasn't involved in Donald Trump's
campaign I just have decided that I'm
gonna have to figure out where I fit and
right now it's just I'd like to say I'm
an American I'm a patriot I'm trying to
figure out on balance which individual
is looking out for the best interest of
America and that's a very it's a lonely
place sometimes because you know
weirdness by cops right you know year
though democrat or republican and some
call themselves independents but the
reality is they lean left
right I'm sort of in the middle there
are things that I think I would take
positions that I take that are more
conservatively aligned and then there
are times when it's more than less
conservatively or more liberally aligned
but I don't think you can just fall into
a box I really don't I think that's the
problem frankly there's some issues that
I really take a strong position on I
mean we were just oh this is so just the
other thing we'll talk about something I
was at the advancing justice seminar its
advance to justice summit which is
hosted by the Charles Koch foundation a
big discussion around reducing the
number of incarcerated Americans and so
someone threw out by 2020 we want to
reduce the number of people incarcerated
by 50% and I paused and I said well
that's dumb
suppose 30% of those people really
should be incarcerated
yeah suppose they're not they should
they absolutely cannot be put back on
the streets you're telling me you're
thinking through is just someone yells
out a phrase and I'm thinking it through
Bertie lordy do these we're going to
tell you why cuz it bothered me cuz
here's the deal I grew up in one of
those fragile communities I grew up and
I shared this with the group I said I
grew up in the area and my grandmother
I'll never forget this I'll never forget
riding up the high school people would
Rob to our windows she you know 60 plus
year old grandmother and me in an ROTC
uniform going to high school
drug dealers run up to our windows
prostitutes who's standing on the corner
in mourning this is 7:30 8 o'clock in
the morning next to a school man ok but
this was the community my grandmother
one day I'll never forget it she said
they wouldn't allow this in white town
they would never put up with this and
why town she was so bothered so she
became committed
she called demanded police she demanded
that you removed these people from our
community and so fast forward you just
want to really release them all back to
our community and and I said this to one
of the attendees I said here's a problem
that sounds great and it's great for you
because they're not coming back to your
community that's that's why this isn't
your problem if you release 50 percent
of these people where do you think
they're coming they're not coming to
suburbia they're going to show back up
in the communities and continue
terrorizing and negatively impact in the
community so on that plan I tell that
story too
say you know listen I am passionate
about it I am bothered I appreciate
well-intended people yeah thinking that
just releasing half the people who are
currently incarcerated into our
communities is a good thing but they
don't think about the impact of that
when my kid can't go out and play in the
streets for being shot my kid can't my
daughter has to walk past these scantily
clad women who were selling themselves
and she begins to think that's normal
that's not the world and you may call
that a non-violent offender but it's not
nonviolent it's actually more violent
because it's working into the psyche as
young people there's so much there
because you could also look at that and
go well a certain amount of those people
are in there for drug offenses not
selling right and and if they had had
better representation or more money they
would have never been in jail in the
first place or their parents so you
can't just blame the government say
that's the thing that's what we're going
to get to 20 and blame the system for
not giving them good lawyers and the
system for incarcerating them too long
and all of that and you forget that a
lot of that stuff started a lot earlier
in their lives now you now you took it
back to the the scary to conservative
point that's right it's not that scared
because by the what my only point is it
doesn't have to be monitored and yeah it
has to be someone it could be a school
teacher that helped infuse morals and
the sense of right and wrong into that
kid but we've got to go back we can't
just wake up and say okay now you've got
a 19 year old who has a long criminal
history no regard for anyone or anything
and say we just think he or she should
not be incarcerated okay then pray tell
what are you going to do what about the
head yeah you ever get an answer to that
I mean if you let these people out I get
that I'm probably with you okay came
from a bad place didn't have the proper
support potentially in jail for doing
drugs not even selling them so the idea
is okay you want to get this person out
of jail even if even if it's just an
economic thing you don't want to have
the system spending money that's right
but now you put them out there you still
have some responsibility I think right
that the system or whatever you want to
call it has some responsibility to make
sure that now you just don't toss this
back into the mix of and what got him
there in the first place
all right and how do you fix that that
is the big question I mean the easy
answer is release them and then what I
would say and then
what and the thing that bothers me is
that many of the people who advocate for
this release release release don't have
to answer the question what because they
have they live in neighborhoods with
gate gated neighborhoods with a lot of
police protection etc so they're not
impacted by they just want to once you
get them out and we we see this listen
and unfortunately with individuals who
suffer with mental mental illness so you
you want them out and then what what are
you gonna do now and that's someone
else's problem and the system as you
call it the non system hasn't answered
that question
[Music]
you
[Music]